If acceleration is proportional to 1/r², I can write an equation like this a₁ /a₂ = (r₁/r₂)⁻²
and the negative is because this is in the denominator and the 2 is because r².
Well let's take a₁ to be our normal acceleration due to gravity g, a₂ would be our acceleration
on the top of the mountain, we call that a₂ still,
r₁ is our distance from the distance center of the earth when we're at sea level
so that's 6,400 km and r₂ is 9 bigger than that because we're on the top of Mt. Everest.
And when you do this math out, you find that the acceleration on the top of Mt. Everest
is equal to the normal acceleration times 0.997.
Well that's exactly equal to 99.7% of the normal acceleration due to gravity,
which means we've decreased by about 0.3% and if you had made this negative, that was okay too.
So going from sea level to the highest place on earth, the acceleration due to gravity
only changes by <1%.
So g really is pretty close to being constant when you're on the surface of the earth.